it's a great day here in Vancouver it's
sunny unfortunately I haven't been able
do much I've been so busy other tasks
cleaning up my videos from the first day
I think I got the hang of iMovie now
there have been a listening while
cleaning up the kitchen after breakfast
read a bit getting out of bed but now
I'm gonna sit down and do some heavy
linking day two of the 90 day challenge
hi there
I started day two with a fair amount of
enthusiasm I'm not gonna do a long
kaleidoscope every day I'm gonna try to
have some comments every day still took
me a while to get the hang of the new
iMovie Alex in our office walked me
through it there's always a lot of
preparation here one of the things I
also spend a good half hour at today is
learning how to type in the Korean
alphabet and that takes a while my Mac
has a Korean keyboard but obviously I
can only click one letter at a time I
have to learn how these words are formed
but I think it's gonna really help me if
I can put that effort into actually
forming words in Korean it's gonna help
me in my reading because reading is a
big part of my learning and I have some
books I don't have them necessarily
handy here some wonderful material from
Korean Broadcasting wonderful quality of
narration and in order to get them into
link I'm gonna have to type them in
myself I'm not gonna type it all in but
I'm gonna choose items that I like that
I like listening to that I have trouble
understanding that I hardly understand
at all now I'm gonna type them in look
up all the words on link review those
words and phrases and then make that
sort of part of my gradual getting used
to the language the fun in any language
is when you get to the point where you
understand it well enough that you can
really listen to things that are
interesting and you start to get into
the culture you have a sense of what's
going on in that country in terms of
current events you have an understanding
of their history and stuff like that I
want to get there as soon as I can
now some of the things I have to do to
get there
include learning how to I believe that's
gonna be my strategy learning how to
type so I can type it in I'm also going
to learn how to write longhand so these
are some of the investments that I have
to make in order to get to the kinds of
things that are enjoyable so it does
raise the question why do we do it you
know when I was watching my wife I was
watching some golf and I was watching it
they were interviewing Clinton who
former President Clinton who had had I
think some operation I'm not sure what
exactly and he was talking about how
it's so important that we take
responsibility for our own health
because then you know we're gonna reap
the benefits we're gonna live long
they're gonna live healthier and so
forth and so on and it's the same with
language learning it's so enjoyable to
be able to participate in other cultures
we have to take the responsibility to do
that that's why we do it that's why the
three months if that can kind of stir
people up get them catapulted to a level
where they can really enjoy the language
then then the sort of language learning
just becomes a an enjoyable exploration
you no longer feel as if you're working
but the initial period this this three
months you know it is it is an effort it
requires discipline I think I got maybe
three and a half or so four hours in
today one way or another if I include
all the little bits and pieces while
watching dishes driving the car cleaning
the garage as well as dedicated reading
and learning how to type and Korean and
so forth so no fancy kaleidoscope today
I am going to be doing some of these
what people call level up I had to use
all Moses's terminology I'm gonna do be
doing some of those and I'm also going
to be telling you what what I considered
be are useful things to do call them
tips or so forth as we go but I'm gonna
try to have a video every day it may not
be every day but I'm gonna try and I'm
also gonna have a daily entry on my
diary log that's it for today end of day
two